انتخابات التجديد النصفي الامريكي تجري
هذا العام في الثامن من تشرين الثاني
نوفمبر القادم تسمى نصفيا لانها تنظم في
منتصف ولايه رئيس التي تدوم اربع سنوات
وهي تشمل جميع مقاعد مجلس النواب وعددها
435 كما يجري التنافس فيها على ثلث مقاعد
مجلس الشيوخ البالغ عددها 100 اضافه الى
انتخاب حكام معظم الولايات ومسؤولها
المحليين وكذلك المجالس التشريعيه
للولايات ينتخب اعضاء مجلس النواب لمده
عامين بينما تمتد ولايه اعضاء مجلس الشيوخ
ست سنوات وتكمل واهميه هذه الانتخابات في
ان من يسيطر على الكونجرس يتحكم في سن
التشريعات وتمرير القوانين والرقابه
المالكيه وبالتالي يرسم معالم العامين
المتبقيين في فتره الرئيس كما يتولى حزب
الاغلبيه قياده لجان المهمه في السيسي
النواب او شيوخ تقوم الفلسفه الدستوريه
لهذه الانتخابات على انها عوده الى
الناخبين في الحكم على المنظومه السياسيه
على فترات متقاربه اي كل عامين في هذه
الحاله لكن ما هي اتجاهات التصويت تاريخيا
عاده ما يخسر للحزب الحاكم الانتخابات
النصفيه في احد المجلسين او كليهما استشير
والاحصاءاته انه من بعد الحرب العالميه
الثانيه اجريت انتخابات نصفيات 19 مرات
وفي سبعه عشره منها خسر حزب الرئيس مقاعد
في الكونغرس بمتوسط سته وعشرين مقعدا في
مجلس النواب واربعه في مجلس الشيوخ فهل
يتمكن الديمقراطيون من قلب هذه المعادله
والفوز ان تكون النتيجه في مصلحه
الجمهوريه
[موسيقى]